hi you guys must be new to town right
new to town but not new to the country
we just moved from California oh we just
wondered uh if you wouldn't mind if your
daughter played with our daughter Audrey
say hi
why
slides off limits to Ching chongs
cute
you want to be best friends look at me
look at me look at me now guess who's
going back to the motherland it's a big
deal going to your birth country we used
to talk about it all the time when we're
little remember Grand Adventure to find
your birth mother so proud of you
y'all calling me crazy you're my
translator in Beijing Audrey I got you
ready
[Laughter]
Kat lives there now your famous college
roommate you ready to lose to a
celebrity
Dead Eye is coming by the way is that
your cousin hey Audrey oh hi hey
where did that come from
you know I think I get it I called the
adoption agency and she lives in high
Ching okay will you guys come with me
[__] yes [__] I love a grand Adventure
oh hi so nice to see in America what do
you do for work it's the cops are doing
a bag check
[Music]
you're drug dealers now [__]
condom we can't get caught with drugs in
China we'll get jailed for life
never come to China people are always
thinking that I have this perfect life I
don't belong anywhere if you do not know
where you come from how do you know who
you are
[Music]
we could still find her our passports
are in my suitcase that got stolen you
know we can bypass the airport security
K-pop Stars everyone remember their
names sassy cutie Lisa Lisa too I don't
believe these girls are seamless girls
show them
um why are we supposed to show you're a
fan of cardi B right yeah but is she
here
there's some [__] in this house
there's some holes
all right honey you good did you get the
coke bags out yeah but only seven and I
think I put in eight just push pull I
mean twist it's not a puppet it's my
[__]